I tell people my sister moved out west.
You're science teacher.
Your husband...
he renovate houses.
You're thinking about
moving but you're gonna wait until the
interest rates go down.
That's not my story.
Before I was an Avenger...
I made mistakes.
And a lot of enemies.
His callsign is Taskmaster.
He controls the Red Room.
They're manipulated.
Fully conscious but no choices.
I should have come back for you.
How many others are there?
Enough.
We have to go back to where it all
started.
So they never do that to anyone again.
We are family.
We fight with you.
You won't win.
I've always found it best
Not to look into the past.
Okay you got a plan what shall I just
stay duck and cover?
My plan was to drive us away!
Well, your plan sucks!
At some point we all have to choose.
Between what the world wants you to be
And who you are.
I made my choice.
I'm done running
Here's what's gonna happen. Natasha don't
slouch!
I'm not slouching! You're going to get
the back hunch!
Listen to mother. Up up!
Alright enough all of you!
I didn't say anything that's not fair!
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Black Widow trailer
video there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs you probably spotted in there
especially a lot of taskmaster Easter
eggs if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing a movie ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and let me know what your favorite
moment from taskmaster in the trailer is
what kind of forever so we'll just start
at the beginning of the trailer footage
and go through it shot by shot yes it
totally looks like he's copying black
panther and has his own vibranium claws
so where did he get that vibranium from
actually we'll start with the identity
of taskmaster just because it seems like
a really big deal everyone's been
wondering who's going to be playing the
character it seems like he's confirmed
my theory that it actually is OT Fagbenle because he posted this to his
Instagram saying taskmaster TM on it
you also have Yelena Belova at several
points during the trailer talking about
taskmaster who he is what's going on he
controls the Red Room he's the one
that's pulling the strings behind this
new generation of black widows gen
during the character male and we see
that when he's going up against black
widow natasha here in a lot of these
different scenes he's way bigger than
her so there was any confusion about who
taskmaster is pretty sure it's going to
be this guy right here but they opened
the trailer with that funny scene of
Yelena Belova having beers with Natasha
Black Widow joking about what her fake
backstory she created for her was when
she left the Red Room to go join shield
in the Avengers you moved out west you
became a science teacher got married
that's a joke about her relationship
with the Hulk because he's a science bro
and now he's become professor Hulk as in
a literal teacher when she jokes about
her husband renovating houses that's a
joke about how the Hulk destroys so many
buildings just the most mundane version
of her backstory that Yelena Belova
could come up with because what they did
in the Red Room was so hardcore and the
missions that they went on that they
were trying so hard to get away from
that kind of stuff this motor home that
she's in just seems like one of the safe
houses that they've been using they
break up a lot of this footage of them
attacking this side
and facility in all the white black
widow costumes but because of some other
footage that they added to this we have
some more context and it actually seems
like this is the prison where Red
Guardian is being kept in there actually
attacking it to break him out these seem
like more of thunderbolt Ross's men
coming to try and arrest them as they're
coming out of this giant facility
blowing up remember there the big scene
where they're like we do this as a
family together where they're all
standing there clasping hands this seems
like it's part of that scene some
slightly different footage of her when
she comes back to Budapest to try and
find Yelena Belova to get her on board
with her mission to take down the Red
Room she talks about the quote-unquote
mistakes and enemies that she made when
she was still part of the Red Room
before she joined shield in the Avengers
then there's a much bigger version of
her vs. taskmaster in that bridge fight
this just seems like a situation where
taskmaster has been clocking her ever
since she entered the country so he's
been watching her for a long time
because we know the taskmaster has those
vibranium claws built into his suit I
asked I don't know if this is actually
going to be a vibranium shield you do start
to wonder where all this vibranium came
from but I suppose ulysses klaw would be
the person to broker that kind of deal
he do remember that ulysses klaw was
trying to sell off bits and pieces of
vibranium that he stole from Wakanda a
long time ago that's how we got that
giant scar back in the 90s when black
panthers father tried to chase him down
to take it back that also kind of gives
you the connection to the Black Panther
lineage because even though I think the
taskmaster saw all the Civil War footage
and was watching that and that's how he
learned Black Panthers moves he could
have also watched footage of Black
Panthers father to chaka back in the 90s
even though there'd be very little of
that footage to find you finally see him
watching footage from Iron Man 2 of
black widows fight big flashback
obviously they're going to be referencing
all of black widows movies that she's
appeared in during the Black Widow movie
Iron Man 2 is just the first time that
she appeared inside the MCU the way the
Yelena Belova describes how he's running
the Red Room in this new generation of
black widows makes it sound like they're
brainwashing them on a level that they
did not do before when Natasha Black
Widow went through the program like she
says it they're conscious but describes
them as being more like finger puppets
they don't make decisions on their own
they're all moving under his command
this scene of Yelena Belova and the
white suit on the gurney seems like it's
from present day and because this is
when they're attacking that big Siberian
prison looking place where ray Guardian
is this might just be them as they're
infiltrating the facility to break him
out but obviously while they're talking
about this they're also talking about
taskmaster brainwashing the new black
widows so they're referencing the
original procedures quote-unquote that
Natasha talked about when she graduated
from her red-room program they actually
filmed a lot of scenes for that that
appeared during the Avengers age of
Ultron trailer when she had her sort of
flashbacks that Scarlet Witch gave her
when she messed with all their minds but
I think they cut that way down just
because maybe they thought it was too
much of a drag or too depressing at the
time now they're like no we're going to
give that to you we're going to show you
how to mattock that was for her
this is taskmaster coming to that
mountain retreat where they're all
hanging out earlier in the movie the
footage appears later in the trailer but
chronologically in the movie this
appears after those scenes notice during
this Red Guardian versus taskmaster
fight when he whips out his black
panther vibranium claws he attacks him
in a very cat-like way then spins off of
him this is something right out of a
Black Panther fight because remember
this movie takes place after Captain
America Civil War but before Avengers
infinity war so it also probably takes
place before black panther in the
timeline there's a much bigger scene of
them fleeing from taskmaster in that
giant urban tank that he comes after
them with with those Hawkeye moves
remember he's copying every single one
of the Avengers so we haven't seen every
single little bit of taskmaster footage
yet when she jokes about how crappy
black widows plan is that's actually a
guardians of the galaxy joke they're
pulling from deep space now for their
Easter eggs I hope you have a plan I
have 12% of a plan
the only Avengers moves that we have not
seen taskmaster copy yet or Iron Man
although he's probably copied a lot of
Iron Man technology that we just haven't
seen yet just because Iron Man isn't
known so much for his fighting style is
he's known for his special toys that he
creates the Natasha Black Widow vs. the
army of black widows then you have red
Guardian inside that prison getting
ready to bust out in that scene where he
bust through the door Natasha Black
Widow versus taskmaster again later in
the movie inside whatever this facility
is that's blowing up as they jump out
the window and then chase each other
flying through the sky free falling I
sure you're all happy to see that he has
his sword from the comics as he whips it
out while they're flying through the air
I was wondering when he was going to whip
it out during the trailer just because
we haven't seen it yet we've seen him
used the shield we've seen him pull some
Captain America moves that he's copied
but we haven't seen him with the sword
yet till now it's hard to tell when and
where the scene of Thunderbolt Ross is
taking place but it clearly looks like
they're using the de-aging technology
but here's the thing he's using the
walking cane and there's only a couple
times that we've seen him use the
walking cane and that was near Captain
America Civil War after his
quote-unquote accident that forced him
into retirement technically even though
he's not really retired it's hard to
tell which city this is taking place in
just because it looks like in a really
open area but hopefully like we all have
a big theory about them setting up
Thunderbolts at the end of this with
Thunderbolt Ross and he'll be sort of
reversed Nick Fury moment for the
original Iron Man movie where he showed
up to tell Iron Man about the Avengers
where Thunderbolt Ross shows up in a
post-credits scene to tell some of the
other people like taskmaster about the
Thunderbolts initiative that's why I'm
really hoping that they keep taskmaster
around they don't try to kill him off at
the end of the movie really digging some
of the fight scenes there's a lot more
fight choreography inside this more
recent trailer remember they have the
fight choreographer from John wick
working on this movie so if you're
getting a very John wick vibe from a lot
of the fight scenes that's why it's on
purpose really like this scene of Red
Guardian pulling that same Captain
America shield stop move in the back of
the airplane here when they're trying to
get rid of that person attached to the
front of it
remember Red Guardian was designed to be
basically the Russian copy of Captain
America but because he doesn't learn the
same way the taskmaster does he doesn't
have that visual memory he can't just
watch someone and copy their moves
instantly I'm guessing a lot of the
moves that he watched of Captain
America's footage were from way back
during World War two because when he was
created was actually much more recently
when Captain America was still in the
ice before he came back out before the
first Avengers movie so he'd be watching
archival footage its taskmaster that's
watching the more recent footage from
Winter Soldier that's where taskmaster
is getting all of his Captain America
moves from it'll be funny to see how
many Captain America jokes they use for
his character like the joke the Spider
Man tells during civil war when he says
I hear that shield defies physics just
because the shield always seems to come
back to him like a
boomerang because of the way he throws
it so everyone let me know in the
comments if there's any big Easter eggs
that you spotted in the trailer footage
that I didn't mention in the video
they're probably some more teasers and
clips that they released before the
movie comes out because it's not coming
out till May but we're going to get a venom
2 trailer really soon and then we'll
also get some more Morbius spider-man
trailers I just posted a whole bunch of
Avengers infinity saga deleted scenes
starting with Thor getting the Oded
force you can click here to watch that
and everyone click here for my brand new
Thor 4 love and thunder Christian Bale
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!